despite kanye west's ongoing divorce
from kim kardashian he plans to stay as
close as possible to her and their kids
literally close
i'm rolling with it earlier this week et
learned that the 44 year old rapper
purchased a 4.5 million dollar home on
the same street as his estranged wife
and four children north saint chicago
and salm and now a source is opening up
to e.t explaining the thinking behind
the grammy winners decision quote kanye
really wanted to buy a home near kim and
their kids to be close to them kanye saw
a house on kim's block was on the market
and jumped at the chance to get it plus
the source says the musician thinks it
will be easier to co-parent with kim if
they live close to each other
but that's not kanye's only intention
the source adds that the grammy winner
also wants to win kim back and he
believes he still has a chance
so what does the skims founder think
about the purchase well our source says
kim is fine with it and agrees with
kanye quote she feels like it will be
easier to co-parent and watch their kids
in privacy i always believe and trust in
him that he will eventually explain
himself because i know his heart but
this isn't kanye's first attempt at
getting kim back earlier this month kim
attended kanye's free larry hoover
benefit concert when he changed a lyric
in his song runaway that was pretty
telling
i need you to run right back with me
i mean it was just fun do something for
my heart then there was this moment from
kanye's november interview on the drink
champs podcast
snl making my wife say i divorced him on
tv because they just wanted to get that
bar off and i ain't never even seen the
papers we're not even divorced cause
they ain't no joke to me but when it
comes to a reconciliation well kim has
made it very clear it's not possible in
early december the reality star filed to
be declared legally single and move
forward with their divorce in court
talks obtained by e.t kim states that
her relationship with kanye is quote
unsalvageable and says there's no
possibility of saving the marriage
through counseling but the jesus walks
rapper's feelings are very important to
kim back in november a source told et
that the beauty mogul is very protective
of kanye and it's why she's been keeping
her new relationship with snl comedian
pete davidson low-key
i mean i like you just the way you are
now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
and it seems like kim is very happy
right now
it's a different experience for sure a
source recently told et that the pair is
enjoying their time together quote pete
is a romantic and goes out of his way to
make kim feel special kim thinks pete is
hysterical and he's constantly making
her laugh but they also have been
connecting on a deeper level
[Music]